Trump could not directly fire Dr fauci
without the move going through the
administrative judge or a late EO so
right and so this is a fair point Trump
could not just fire fauci he could have
sidelined him he could have done things
but he he even says he like the left
would have gone crazy he was worried of
political backlash well and and keep in
mind look at that sounds to the left but
I'm sorry what happened when Trump fired
Comey right is that he turned into a
community
well no he that's what started the
special counsel of Mueller investigation
against him for two years because he
fired firing of Comey dude they they
still have the fake tweet up like the
DeSantis worm has not even taken down
the the lies and the fake news that they
have made there's look there's nothing
more deeply offensive to me than someone
intentionally trying to trick people for
power